Once again, welcome.
We're so glad that each one of you are here.
It's wonderful to welcome Micah as well there in the back.
And he's the newest member of the church.
The baby was just born if you didn't realize.
And so we are going to continue in our series on our Statement of Faith though.
So if you've got a Bible, if you could turn with me to John chapter 3.
And if you've got a worship guide on the back of that worship guide, it's got the
next little section of our Statement of Faith.
This series is a firm foundation.
And it's looking at what we believe and why it matters.
And we've come now to our Statement on Salvation, which I'll read so we can all see that together
and then we'll come to God's Word more importantly and see what God says to us there.
Our Statement says,
We believe that sinners are saved by sovereign grace through the life, death and resurrection
of Christ, by which he accomplished redemption, forgiveness of sins, renewal of life and life
everlasting for his people.
This salvation is received by grace through the gift of faith so that no man can boast.
Well that statement is densely packed and covers some real essential truths that we
won't be able to uncover the detail of each of them this morning.
But we will look at a portion of the Bible that really looks at salvation in a nutshell
and it begins with perhaps the most famous well-known verse in the Bible and that's John
316.
So we're going to read John 316 down to verse 21 together.
Just over a month ago, Bernard Howard came and he preached on the first half of the
chapter where Jesus had just had a conversation with this religious leader called Nicodemus
who'd come to him by night and Jesus spoke to him about the necessity of being born
again.
And then what you then have after that is inspired commentary from John, the author of this book.
If you've got a red letter edition of the Bible like I do, it might have that continuing on
in red letters there to show that Jesus said them but this section is almost certainly
commentary from John.
But please don't let that throw you off for me to say that because all Scripture as
we saw a few weeks ago is given by inspiration of God.
This is just as much Scripture as something that Jesus said.
So we have the inspired Word of God and what we are going to read here holds no less weight
or authority and it's a wonderful summary of what salvation is all about.
All right, so let's read John 316 down to the end of verse 21.
For God so loved the world that he gave his only son that whoever believes in him
should not perish but have eternal life.
For God did not send his son into the world to condemn the world but in order that the world
might be saved through him.
Whoever believes in him is not condemned but whoever does not believe is condemned already
because he is not believed in the name of the only son of God.
And this is the judgment.
The light has come into the world and people love the darkness rather than the light
because their works were evil.
For everyone who does wicked things hates the light and does not come to the light lest
his works should be exposed.
But whoever does what is true comes to the light so that it may be clearly seen that
his works have been carried out in God.
This is the Word of the Lord.
Let's pray once again.
Lord, thank You so much for Your Word that You have given us.
Lord, I pray that You would open our eyes by Your Spirit to see more of Jesus and what You
have done for us in Him.
We pray this in His name.
Amen.
Well, back in 2010, a major news story broke out of Chile and it soon spread around the
world.
33 miners had been trapped in a mine that had collapsed.
I don't know if you remember seeing that back then, but people thought initially there's
no way these men could have survived that accident.
But soon it was discovered that not only had some of them survived, all of them had survived
the accident.
But getting to them, to rescue them seemed like an absolutely impossible task.
So it took a lot of effort.
It was the coordinated effort of, I think it was over 300 people were involved in
the rescue team.
And then 69 days later, imagine that length of time down there.
They emerged from out of the darkness into the light.
They had been rescued.
Every single one of them were saved.
And you can see the video footage as they're emerging from the ground.
There's absolute joy and tears that are on their faces and on the faces of their loved
ones as they were rescued.
In the end, not one of all 33 of these miners was lost.
And there's a word in the Bible that describes what those miners experienced that way, that
day rather.
And that's the word sozo.
So the disciples were in the boats with Jesus one day and this huge storm came on the sea
of Galilee and these disciples thought they were going to die.
The ship was going to sink and they cried out sozo.
They cried out, Lord, save us.
That's the word, save, salvation.
We're in danger here.
We're going to drown.
Save, they said.
Without Jesus' ministry, you see people coming to him with all kinds of illnesses and diseases
in need of being healed, being made well.
And he healed so many of them.
But the word healed sometimes or being made well is that same word.
People are saved.
They're rescued from these physical illnesses or diseases that they had.
And they would cry out, save me, Lord.
But in the New Testament, this word is more often and more importantly used to speak not
of what we might say is temporal salvation.
It's used to speak of eternal salvation.
Yes, Jesus in compassion saved people from earthly predicaments and ailments.
But the primary reason he came into the world was to bring about eternal salvation.
This is the salvation we're looking at today.
The Apostle Paul would go on to write in 2 Timothy chapter 1 and verse 15, Christ Jesus came into
the world to save sinners.
Jesus said in Luke 1910, the Son of Man has come to seek and to save the lost.
This is the kind of salvation we read about in John 3.17 that we just read.
He said, God did not send his Son into the world to condemn the world, but that the
world through him might be saved.
And I recognize in our context, like getting saved is one of those Christian expressions
that get thrown around a lot in this part of the world.
But that doesn't necessarily mean that it is understood or that it has been experienced
by the person who is saying it.
It's just one of those common things that we hear about in the kind of church world
today.
But if this is our greatest need and it is, it is crucial to know what this salvation is
all about.
So for the next few minutes, we're going to press into this by just asking four questions
and we're going to see what our text says to answer those four questions.
We'll probably spend a little bit more time on the first two and a bit less time on
the second two questions.
Let me tell you what the questions are.
One, why do we need to be saved?
Two, who saves us?
Three, how can I know that I am saved?
And four, what are we saved for?
So that's where we're heading.
So first of all, why do we need to be saved?
If you just think about the word saved or rescued, it means that we're like in a
perilous situation that's implied in the word.
If you need to be rescued, you are in trouble in some way.
So we might ask, well, what kind of peril are we in if we need to be
saved from something?
Well, John helps us to see the kind of peril that humanity is in apart from
salvation.
We need to be saved because there at the end of verse 16, we are perishing.
We're perishing.
We're dying.
The penalty of sin is death.
Because of our sin, we've been separated from God, who is the source of true
eternal spiritual life, separated from the source of true life.
And without being reunited, reconciled to Him, we will perish eternally.
So we're perishing.
Chapter three in verse 36, it's not there in your worship guides, but if you've
got a Bible in front of you or on your phone, you can see in verse 36.
It says, whoever believes the Son has life, but whoever does not obey the Son
shall not see life, but the wrath of God remains on Him.
So we need to be saved because we are under the wrath of God.
If we're not saved, we will remain under that wrath.
And a lot of scary movies, horror movies were consumed over the course of this
past week, probably more than any other week of the year.
Let me tell you, if you want a good idea for a horror movie, look at numbers
chapter 21 in your Bible.
Numbers 21, we heard about it a month ago when Bernard was here.
But you got the people of God or the Israelites, they're wondering in the
wilderness, and instead of being thankful for what they'd been rescued from and
trusting God to provide for them in the days ahead, they were moaning and
they were complaining rather than trusting and praising God.
So here comes the scary part.
As an act of judgment, there was an outbreak of venomous snakes in the
camp.
Imagine being one of them in the camp.
And this is the stuff of nightmares.
And people were getting bitten.
And these were these venomous snakes.
Why is there getting bitten?
People were dying.
And so to be bitten by one of these snakes meant a certain death.
All right, we'll return to that story in just a second.
But just to say, when you look at John 3.16 when it says, shall not perish.
Well, what perishing is he referring to?
Well, if you go back to verse 15, it's referring to that story where people
were perishing.
So he's just talked about that.
And now he's talking about perishing in verse 16.
So as in the accounts in Numbers 21 of people being snake bitten, instead of
receiving God's gracious gifts and giving Him thanks and following Him in faith,
we set our desires on what is forbidden and our words and our actions soon follow.
And that's been the case from the Garden of Eden to the present day.
And because of that, because we've gone our own way, we are perishing,
separated from the source of life under judgment in a place where we cannot save
ourselves, just like the people who had been bitten before.
Now remember who the audience was that Jesus had been speaking to earlier in
John chapter three.
You know, it's Nicodemus.
This was a man who appeared to have it all together, a religious leader.
And so to admit that he needed to be saved would be to admit that he was
just like the people that his peers looked down upon to say that he wasn't
already right with God.
That would have been a really humbling experience for him to say,
I'm just like those people who are perishing and needed to be saved from that.
But he did.
It's a humbling experience we all need to go through.
If you look at verse 19 as well, John goes on to say this.
Remember Nicodemus came to Jesus by night as now when you get to verse 19,
it says, and this is the judgment.
The light has come into the world.
This is Jesus coming and people love the darkness rather than the light
because their works were evil for everyone who does wicked things,
hates the light and does not come to the light, lest his work should be exposed.
So you have those two options there.
One is you you hold on to sinfulness in the dark or you come out
into the light of what God has revealed to us in Jesus and in doing that,
your sin is exposed.
Yes, but you're saved.
You're forgiven.
You're reconciled.
So you have to say, am I going to hold on to this in the dark or am I going
to go through the humbling experience of that being revealed so that I might
be saved?
Let me think about it this way.
Imagine a couple of teenagers and they're they're going out in the woods
somewhere and they see this fence and they see like, like do not enter.
No trespassing.
And then there's also one that says no swimming.
Like, well, I want to swim like I want to get there.
If there's a pool back there, I want to get and so they they talk to each other,
a couple of them, and they decide they're going to jump the fence and they go to
swim. They get there and there's a quarry.
And this and so not only are you going to swim, we're going to jump off
this cliff into the quarry and so they jump off the cliff of the quarry
and into the water and they're having a great time swimming around there
in the water. But as they look around, they realize there's no place
to get out of this quarry.
So there was a reason why the danger signs were up.
But now they're stuck in this predicament.
And so they've got a choice to make now.
They need to be rescued.
There's no way they're getting out of there.
But in order to cry out for salvation or rescue, if you will,
they're going to have to own up to the fact that they trespass,
that they went somewhere they knew they shouldn't go.
All right. So what are they going to do?
Of course, the right thing to do is to cry out for help,
even though it means the exposure of having gotten something wrong.
And that's the case for all of us.
We're going to be saved.
We have to be willing to say to admit that we have messed up,
that we are in need.
All right. So that's why we need to be saved.
So who saves us?
It's clear from how it speaks of our need that we cannot save ourselves.
There's nothing we can do.
The scripture is abundantly clear on this that God saves.
He is mighty to save.
Salvation is not something we do for ourselves.
We're totally unable.
It's something that God does for us.
It's not a reward. It's a gift.
All right. So in our opening scripture in Isaiah 45, God says,
turn to me and be saved all the ends of the earth for I am God.
And there is no other.
This is what we see in John 3.
The focus here is on what God has done for us.
So God is the cause and our salvation is the result.
And this God who saves us is that one God spoken of in Isaiah 45.
This God is Father, Son, and Holy Spirit.
And every person of the Trinity is involved in the work of salvation.
So where do we see God the Father?
What does he do?
Well, let's see verse 16.
God so loved the world.
So the Father loves the world.
So it isn't that like,
the Father really wants to condemn us,
but then the merciful Son really loves us and kind of stands in the way.
No.
It's that the Son, when He comes, He shows the love of the Father.
Right. So God so loved the world.
Right. So it speaks here of God's love in a couple of ways.
It'll draw our attention to one is God's love is extensive.
So throughout John and the rest of scripture,
we do see that there is a special love that God has the Father has for His Son.
There's love within the God had as it were.
And then there's also a special love that God has for His people, for His disciples.
You see this back in the Old Testament with His love for His people there.
So there's a special love for those who have been brought into this relationship with Him.
But here, our attention is drawn to God's love for the whole world.
So God didn't send His Son purely to say, save the Israelites and then condemn the rest of the world.
No, His salvation is for all the world, for all the peoples of the world.
So it speaks of God's love as being extensive, but it also speaks of God's love as being intense.
Let's not miss that word. God so loved the world.
You know, in the U.S., sometimes we throw around the word love pretty loosely.
Like, you know, I love my son or I love my daughter and I love pumpkin spice lattes.
You know, I don't, by the way, I don't know if I try to think of something we might just say.
Like, I love this or I love that.
Well, in scripture, you've got different words for love that show like intensity or direction of love.
And like, this is the most or the deepest love.
This is the love of God being spoken of here. This is agape love.
And how intense is God's love? Well, here's how intense His love is.
God so loved the world that He was willing to give His only Son.
All right, so God loves the world. The Father, the Father gives the only Son.
So love isn't just a sentiment. It's seen in our actions.
And God's actions show that His love is the greatest love ever known because He was willing to give His one
and only Son. One more thing about the Father.
So He loves, He gives, and He does so with specific intent in view as well.
So it's a broad statement here to say He loved the world so much that He gave His Son,
but then it narrows again. He gives His Son with a specific intent in view that whoever believes in Him
should not perish but have everlasting life.
And so salvation is offered to the entire world to anyone who will believe.
But when you believe, you can be certain that salvation has been accomplished for you by Christ.
So Christ fully accomplished salvation for everyone who believes in Him.
So God sends Him with that specific intent to display His love to the world,
to save everyone who would believe in Christ.
Alright, so God the Father is involved. God the Son is clearly involved as well.
So while Jesus isn't the only person in Scripture spoken about as being like a child of God or a son of God,
there is a uniqueness to the sonship of Jesus.
He is the eternal Son of God who is a distinct person and yet one with His Father.
And when we look at the Son here, we see that not only was the Father willing to give His Son the Son,
but the unique Son of God was willing to go.
So a couple of things. What does the Son do?
If you look back at verse 13 of the chapter, we see that Jesus was willing to descend into the world.
So think back to those Chilean miners as they're descending into the depths of the earth.
It was like 2,300 feet was how far they were trapped in there.
And so at the end of the day, once they finally got a kind of shaft built,
somebody had to be willing to descend and to take the risk to go to where those miners were.
In Scripture we see this much deeper descent that is made by the Son of God.
He descends from heaven's glory down into this world that had rejected Him.
He became a man without ceasing to be God.
When He arrived, they called His name what? What were they to call His name?
Jesus. What does the name Jesus mean?
Savior.
So the Savior came to where we were that He might save us and bring us to where He is.
He descended that we might ascend.
He became a man that He might die as a man in our place,
which shows us the next thing that Jesus does for us.
Verse 15, it's talked about the Son of Man being lifted up.
So how was the Son of Man lifted up?
Well, just as Moses lifted up the serpent in the wilderness.
Do you remember the story? All right, let's go back there.
All right, so we're not just leaving.
They weren't just dying of these snake bites.
God gave a solution that was there.
Moses was instructed to make a bronze serpent and to lift up this bronze serpent on a pole.
And when that serpent was lifted up, everyone who looked at that bronze serpent that was made would live.
They would be healed instantly.
So they looked and they lived.
So like if you look at an ambulance today, by the way, what do you see?
The symbol at the side, you get a pole with a serpent on it.
So that's still symbol of healing is still being used today.
So that bronze serpent, imagine being one of those people.
It's a reminder of the seriousness of their sin as they're looking at it.
Like this is what happened as a result of what we did. Yes.
And they're also reminded of the consequences of their sin as they look at this bronze serpent that was lifted up.
But also as they look, they're also seeing the salvation that God has provided for them.
They're healed. They're rescued. They're saved.
And so Jesus says as Moses lifted up that serpent in the wilderness, even so must I be lifted up.
This is him speaking about how he was going to be lifted up upon the cross.
So what do we see when we look at the cross, like the people in the wilderness?
As we look at him on the cross, we see that's how serious our sin is.
It was so serious that the very Son of God had to die because of our sin.
As we look at the cross, we were reminded of the consequences of our sin as he dies there.
He's perishing there.
But as we look to Jesus on the cross, we see the source of salvation.
We see what God has done for us.
We see that there on the cross, God's love is being displayed that Jesus is willing to bear
the curse of our sin in our place that he desires to save us.
He perished that we might live and live forever.
So God, the Son saves.
Also, God, the Holy Spirit is involved in salvation, too.
So salvation was planned by the Father and it was accomplished by the Son.
And now salvation is applied by the Spirit.
Once again, you got to go earlier in John 3 to that account with Nicodemus.
And Jesus spoke to him about the need to be born again, to have a new spiritual life.
But he described that new life as being born of the Spirit.
And so Jesus has just said that you've got to be born of the Spirit.
And now he says in John 3.16, whoever believes in Jesus will have everlasting life.
This is that new life that he was speaking about earlier.
So we have life when the Spirit gives us life.
We don't bring about the new birth any more than we brought about our first physical birth.
The Spirit gives life.
So salvation is a gift of God, Father, Son, and Holy Spirit.
You might then say, OK, we need to be saved.
God saves us.
How can I know that I'm saved?
That's the next question.
Like if it's a work of God, like how can I know that that has happened in me?
I can't save myself.
How can I know that I'm saved?
Thankfully, the passage shows us not only God's vantage point, but our vantage point as well.
God so loved the world that He gave His only Son that whoever what believes in Him
should not perish, that have eternal life.
So God saves.
Who does He save?
Everyone who believes in Christ.
Everyone who puts their faith in Him.
This past week was a major holiday, which I'm sure you all celebrated on Friday.
Of course, I'm talking about Reformation Day in 508 years.
Since the Protestant Reformation, you're all ready to nail your 95 reces to the wall.
Sorry, that was really cheesy.
But I did see a few things pop up about how it was the anniversary of the Protestant Reformation.
I won't geek out too much there, but one of the crucial truths that was recovered that's
been there all along before us in Scripture is that salvation is by grace alone through
faith alone in Christ alone.
We cannot save ourselves.
The grace of God is received through the empty hands of faith as we trust in Christ.
Let's see, look at Ephesians 2, 8 and 9, for by grace you have been saved through faith.
And that not of yourselves, it is the gift of God, not of works, lest anyone should boast.
One of you put me on to an article actually about how trick or treating is a good illustration
of grace.
You come with an empty bag, you might have a costume or not, and people are generous
on the night.
Give away the candy, whether you've done enough to earn it or not, it's not about earning, you
receive the gift.
So God has done all of this work to save us.
How do we receive it?
Well, there's nothing I can do.
So I hold out my hands in faith and just receive the gift of eternal life by believing
in Christ, resting in Him, putting my trust in Him.
And by the way, that's the story about the snake bite and whatever.
That's a wonderful way to think about faith, because when they looked at the bronze serpent,
it was then by looking that they are healed.
What is faith if not looking?
Or looking away from ourselves.
In fact, Hebrews 12 and verse 2 defines faith as looking to Jesus.
So we're looking to Him and trusting in Him.
Not our wrongdoings.
Not our good works.
But in Jesus alone, because it's He alone who saves.
So we're believing in Christ.
So if I'm looking at my own works, even works that I think are empowered by God's grace,
how will I know that I've worked enough to be accepted by God?
I'll never know.
But if I'm looking to Christ's work, His finished work, and Him alone, I can know that I'm
saved not because I'm good enough but because He's done everything necessary to save me.
Because He's a glorious Savior.
That's how we know we're saved, by looking to Jesus, trusting in Him.
What does God save us for though?
That's the last question.
God saves us for something that whoever believes in Him should not perish but have eternal
life.
So He saves us to give us eternal life.
That speaks to a couple of things.
One is it certainly speaks to the life to come.
Life after death, if you will.
We were made for a life that lasts forever.
So in the life of a believer, salvation is a past events.
But you can also see in Scripture, it's also spoken of as a present reality that God keeps
us and also salvation is spoken of as a future reality when Jesus comes again and He saves
us from the final judgment.
So Hebrews chapter 9 verse 28 says, Christ will return to save those who are eagerly waiting
for Him.
So we're already saved but we will be saved because we'll be brought to be with Him forever.
So there is an eternal life to come.
So those who trust in Christ now will be saved forever.
But the thing I wanted to press into a little bit more though is the fact that eternal
life is a present reality.
It's not just about the life to come, it's about right now.
So this is not just about a happily ever after in the future.
It's about a life that God wants to give us now.
And that life that God gives us now is everlasting life.
It goes on forever.
It doesn't become everlasting once we die.
God gives us that everlasting life and that life continues on.
And that eternal life comes through a living union with Jesus that you go on to see elsewhere
in the Gospel of John.
Like we're, Jesus is the vine and we are the branches for example.
So everybody who believes in Jesus is united to Him and it's in being united to Him that
we are restored to a right relationship with God.
So we said to be perishing is to be disconnected, to be cut off, to be separated from the
source of everlasting life.
And in Jesus we are reconciled to God and brought back into that life through Him.
And through Him we know the God that is the source of life.
So it's not just a life from Him, it's a life with Him.
It's very present with us.
So Jesus will go on to say in John 17.3 in a prayer.
He's praying to his Father.
He says, this is eternal life.
Here's how Jesus defines it.
This is eternal life that they know you speaking to his Father.
So eternal life is about knowing God.
You know sometimes you hear the accusation that well if you believe that salvation is through
faith alone, well then surely you'll just then live as you please.
If you think it's just a gift and you don't have to earn it, well then that's just
a license to do whatever you want to.
But that can't be true if we're truly connected to the source of life.
If our lives are united to Jesus Himself.
And here's the reality, when we are saved, we are united to Christ.
We are fully saved in that moment.
All of His righteousness belongs to us.
But then throughout our lifetime, God by His Spirit works on us to bring that righteousness
out to help us to live the life that we were made for.
And we're not doing that in order to earn salvation.
We're doing that because we have been saved.
And God has given us everything to live the life that we were made for that's found in Jesus.
So we read this in Galatians 2.20, Paul says, I, this is his old self, I am crucified with
Christ.
Nevertheless, I live, here's eternal life.
Nevertheless I live, yet not I, but Christ lives in me.
And the life that I now live in the flesh, I live by faith in the Son of God who
loved me and gave Himself for me.
So it's living out the life of Christ by faith.
So being united to Jesus is a transformational reality because Jesus Himself now lives in
us by the Spirit.
And then one day He will bring us to glory where we will be like Him because we will
see Him as He is.
But by God's grace, I hope all of us can say by faith, looking to Jesus, God has saved
me.
And it will continue to look to Jesus.
God is saving me.
And as we think about the future, we can say, and on that day, God will save me.
And all of it has been given to us freely in Jesus.
And those miners in Chile were finally brought out from the darkness into the light.
They were all wearing T-shirts.
And you can go back and see the videos as they come out, joy and tears, and they have
these T-shirts on.
And these T-shirts were made for them because that's people like, heard them and heard
their story and whatever.
They kept saying these two words over and over in down in the darkness.
And now that they were in the light, they were saying it over again.
And those two words on their T-shirts were, gracias Señor.
I do not speak Spanish, but I can work that one out.
What were they saying?
They were saying, thank you, Lord, thank you, Lord, thank you, Lord.
He was the one they were praising for their salvation on that day.
So how should we respond to this amazing gift of salvation that's been provided for us
freely in Jesus?
I hope we can all say that I've received it by faith and I give him thanks.
It may also teach us to live in gratitude for the salvation that we've been given.
Knowing that God has provided everything we need to be reconciled to him, to live
the life that we've been made for and to be with him forevermore.
And then we live in hope, giving him thanks for the salvation that is to come when
Jesus returns.
Let's pray.
Lord, thank you so much.
Thank you, Lord, for the salvation that you have provided for us in Jesus.
Lord, thank you that you are God of love and grace, even to the point of being
willing to give your son for us.
And so Lord, I pray by the help of your spirit that every single one of us
here would look away from ourselves, both our sinfulness and our own self-righteous
efforts would help us to look to Jesus and put our trust in him and him alone.
Lord, that our hearts would cry out, thank you for what you've done for us in him.
Lord, receiving this salvation by grace, I pray that you'd help us to live in
gratitude as well, relying upon your grace every day.
And I pray that the life of Christ will be known in us, best now and forevermore.
Amen.